did you know that after the 1986
Chernobyl nuclear disaster at reactor
number 4 that the other reactors on that
site were not shut down permanently in
fact they were kept running producing
electricity by workers who were brought
in by train every day to work on those
other reactors the last of which was
shut down around the year 2000 that is
just one of the many surprising facts I
found out while shooting a documentary
for TV which is called uranium twisting
the Dragons tail now while we were
shooting this documentary I would take
out my little camera and shoot small
pieces while they were setting up the
big camera this is James
no but that's allowed me to make some
youtube videos for you including the
most radioactive places on earth and
I'll have a few more of those videos
coming out very soon but what I wanted
to show you was the trailer for this
documentary and I want you guys to check
out this trailer let me know what you
think and I will put at the end of the
trailer the dates that this documentary
will be aired in your area it'll be
played in the u.s. in Australia and in
Europe so stay tuned to the end of this
trailer to check out when it'll be on in
your neck of the woods so thank you guys
so much for watching this YouTube
channel because without it I never would
have got the job hosting this TV
documentary and I really hope you enjoy
it we put so much work into it and it
looks amazing
so check it out here it is
legends say there's a world beneath this
one where a dragon lies sleeping they
say be careful how you wake the dragon
around a turn of the 20th century
uranium is almost unknown it is
basically worthless but then in 40 years
just a single generation it becomes the
most desirable and terrifying Rock on
earth
this is uranium and as a physicist I'm
fascinated by its unique scientific
properties but even more so by how this
one rock has shaped the entire modern
world uranium changes everything
uranium makes the modern world uranium
is a dream clean limitless power or a
nightmare of a silent and poisoned earth
its fault is hot here it's really come
with me on a journey to find the most
desirable this is a nuclear reactor and
the most hated rock on earth
it's just that fear if it blows what's
gonna happen is how did we unleash the
elemental force within uranium what
happened when we woke the dragon this is
the story of how a rock changed the
world
you